I do have access to a pulse PEMF machine, so a pulse is a brand of PEMF machine that's a very
high-gose PEMF machine that typically only a clinic would have because they're quite expensive.
So I do have access to a pulse PEMF machine at my nantrapads office is two times per week
or a half hour effective or should I do more or longer sessions. So when we used to see people
in our office, cancer patients in our office, or PEMF, we have a pulse PEMF, that's the best one
of the market right now. We used to do one hour long sessions, so we do one hour long sessions,
so I think if you could get up to an hour long, I think that would be better.
But of course the cost could be a factor. Is there an at-home version of PEMF that would deliver
similar results? I don't want to waste money on something that won't approach the effectiveness
of the pulse. So the cost of a PEMF machine, whether it's an at-home model or an
incline model, is partly based upon the gouse output of the machine. So the pulse PEMF machine
put out about 30,000 gouse. A lot of the at-home ones put out less than a thousand gouse. Like the
beamer I think is like 700 gouse, the IMRS is like 7 or 800 gouse. Most of the at-home ones are pretty
low gouse. We can get an at-home model from a company. It's not pulse that makes it, but it's a
different company. That's a good company. But it's about 7,000 to 9,000 gouse, but it's also about 9,000
dollars. So they're expensive. So you pay basically based upon the gouse. Now unfortunately the beamer
that puts out only like 700 gouse still costs about 5 to 7,000 dollars. So I don't, if you have that
or somebody can borrow you what or use what, I still think there could be value in it. Go ahead and use
it. But I wouldn't suggest purchasing something like that. You're going to purchase what you have to
get one that puts out at least 7 to 10,000 gouse. The pulse can be about there like 35 to 40,000
dollars. So that's completely out of possibilities for most people. But the at-home ones that are 7 to 9,000
gouse are like 9,000 dollars. You really want to invest in that. You can contact me. We don't have
other website. I don't think. But I've sold a bunch of those to different people that wanted to have
a therapy clinic in their own house. Because you could use the pulse first. You could use the
peat you met for a lot of musculoskeletal things. So you could justify purchasing it because other
family members would use it. Lots of people that have purchased that, you know, said their kids are
athletes and their husband, you know, wants to use it at home. And then you could use it every day.
And so there's benefits to have it. But they're not cheap either. So this contact our office is
that really interests you.